even the idea of a mandate if we think
about that for a minute um
when you're mandating
something that is a matter of health
a personal medical choice
in some sense
a mandate is either unnecessary or
unjustified
it's unnecessary
for those who would have
done it anyway complied anyway
um and it's arguably unjustified if we
consider
the most important
thing to preserve for humans for quality
of life and for flourishing and for
happiness
is autonomy and that word autonomy
comes from two greek words that means
self-rule right and someone might say
well we don't let people do just
whatever they want so you know you have
to get a driver's license to drive a car
and things like that
yes that's true
but
when it comes to mandating what goes
into or happens to a person's body
there's an intimacy there there's
something inalienable about
the body and the physiological processes
in the body there's an intimacy that's
broken an invasion into
what should be private by the state and
that's why
i think that these um health care
mandates are trespassing or crossing a
line that they should never cross
and
you know i've had some really
interesting discussions with with
academics with physicians
uh about whether or not in principle
there are situations where
a health care mandate would be
appropriate
and
my thinking and i've thought about this
a lot you know and there's often this
reference to the smallpox case
massachusetts versus jacobson right all
of that and
my feeling about it is though i want to
do more thinking about it is that if
healthcare mandates are ever justified
there needs to be an incredibly high and
almost impossibly high threshold that
has to be met that involves things like
the severity of the viral threat which
is not anything like what we're seeing
right now right so my point to all of
this is that to mandate something is not
just to impose
a blanket rule on a group of people for
whom it doesn't matter much
right um because either
there's a there's a percentage of that
group that will do the thing anyway and
there's a percentage of that group that
will not do the thing and will either do
it because of the mandate under
circumstances of coercion and that's a
serious threat to autonomy
or people who will refuse to abide by
the mandate anyway so what's the purpose
so really the only group it's affecting
is a coerced group of people
[Music]